[Music]
the theme
machado urucú
is in gets and soccer
lupus secano
tomorrow they fail me
wow room
add it and charly tells me you and my baby
[Music]
all the sacred space all space that
one sees to a certain extent has a
level of that reality
but obviously all I have is
because of the
sacred water all
[Music]
once
and
my name is Jorge Wake Patrick and I am
Mapuche in that it is indicating the
territory an impressive amount of
land is taken away through different
legislations laws and titles that
The functions have been handed over and well, to
recover what has been
taken from the Mapuches and we have
our regular functions, in this
case as custodian of nature
itself, to try to regulate that and, by the
way, in conjunction with organized civil society.
to just fight for a
better well-being and a better future for
our peoples
[Music]